Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten begrüßt alle hier zur 72 Ausgabe und heute hat mich der Weg wieder einmal nach Köln geführt genauer,
in das europäische Astronauten Ausbildungszentrum das EAC das ja hier angesiedelt ist,
auf dem großen DLR Gelände hatte ich schon mal gesprochen mit Samantha cristoforetti und ja heute habe ich auch wieder die Gelegenheit bei den Astronauten einzusteigen und begrüßt meinen Gesprächspartner für heute nämlich,
Mauer Hallo.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Matthias wir hatten ja schon die Freude miteinander vor einigen Wochen sind wir in Kourou aufeinander gestoßen.
Genau da hat mir die Gelegenheit uns wissen Sie informieren wie es weitergeht mit europäischen Raumfahrt im Bereich Raketenentwicklung das Thema Ariane Sex hat manchmal bisschen genauer angeguckt.
Richtig und ja ich wollte ja eigentlich auch den Staaten anschauen leider hat mir da einen zu spät abgeflogen ziviler Flug einen Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht aber du hast es ja mitbekommen.
Genau genau wann.
Aus allernächster Nähe auch noch.
Genau mein toller Start Ariane 5.
Stolz und schneit es sehr beeindruckend also die hat Jannis 50er mit das kräftigste LohnSpiegel was da haben beim Start da geht richtig was ab was deutlich beeindruckender als in Sojus Start.
Ja gut im Vergleich werden die wenigsten haben so also wo spielt man es am meisten in den Ohren oder im Bauch.
Sowohl in den Ohren hat auch im Bauch wir haben ja diese diese Feststoffraketen die Booster Diana bei der Sojus nicht und die liefern sehr sehr viel Schub in der Startphase und das merkt man einfach.
Das heißt man kriegt so'n kribbelt im Bauch.
Es war schon richtig auch nicht vibrieren wo man deutlich weiter weg steht als beim soyoustart.
Kribbeln im Bauch dürftest Du ohnehin haben du gehörst ja zu den zu dem europäischen Astronauten Team seid.
Was ist Gaza seit kurzem sagen du bist du auf die Warteliste der dazu gestoßen ist so als als Nachrücker.
Ganz genau seit 20:15 Uhr bin ich eine Ausbildung genau ich gehöre offiziell zur Auswahl 2008-2009 damals waren wir,
zehn Kandidaten die alle Test bestanden hatten aber es gab nur Sex,
Tickets in den Weltraum deswegen hat der Generaldirektor der Isar damals nur Sex Astronauten eingestellt und ich bin sozusagen auf die Warteliste.
Und wie kann es sein dass die Warteliste auch aktiviert wurde.
Ja damals diesen sechs Flügel die waren halt unter der Voraussetzung dass die Eisessen Finanzierung erstmal nur bis 20:15 Uhr gesichert war jetzt aber wissen wir alle die Leuchte 20-24 also das war absehbar dass Europa dann auch neue Astronauten braucht.
Blitzer Zahlen sind Mindestbedarf die man denken muss.
Genau genau ganz genau.
Aber es wird ja auch mit amerikanischen und.
Genau auf das amerikanische Chor wird immer wieder erweitert die haben den Mindestbedarf vor ca 50 Astronauten dauerhaft um alles abdecken zu können und das russische cool hat auch eine Mindestgröße.
Das heißt jetzt gehst du durch diesen ganzen Zauber durch der astronautenausbildung,
das hatte ich ja schon ausführlich wie schon erwähnt mit Samantha cristoforetti vor ihrer ersten Mission schon mal besprochen hier am Meer Zeeman ist aber auch,
an vielen anderen Orten fliegt 1 die ganze Zeit nur um den Planeten oder.
Ja nicht die ganze Zeit aber das stimmt schon im Großteil der Ausbildung wird im Ausland gemacht und zwar,
bietet jede Raumfahrtagentur das training vor Ort an von den eigenen Segmenten das heißt wenn die Astronauten die den Weltraum fliegen sich für das Columbus Modul,
Vorbereiten dann kommen sie alle nach Köln das heißt auch die Amerikaner die Russen die,
Pahna kommen hier nach Köln umgekehrt bedeutet das wenn ich lerne wie der britische Arm zu bedienen ist dann muss ich nach Kanada fliegen oder in die USA fliegen.
Und ja wenn ich lerne wie das japanische Segment zu bedienen ist dann fliege ich nach Japan.
Und jetzt hier im RC wird gerade fleißig Chinesisch gelernt habe ich gehört.
Genau ich lasse jetzt Chinesisch und Russisch und das sind ja mit die zwei Optionen die ich dann auch haben werde in den Weltraum zu fliegen eventuell auf einer Sojus-Kapsel eventuell auf einer chinesischen chencho Kapsel.
Oder auch eventuell auf einer der neuen kommerziellen amerikanischen Kapseln hat viele Optionen und ich weiß jetzt nicht wo mich der Weg hinführt.
Damit ansehen vielleicht mal so zu deinem Hintergrund bisher nicht als Astronaut geboren worden was.
Sie hatten wie sah denn deine Reise sozusagen bis in die heutige Position aus also womit hast du angefangen immer in Wissenschaften unterwegs gewesen.
Ja von der Ausbildung her bin ich Werkstoffwissenschaftler also.
Das studiert in verschiedenen Ländern Europas also integrierte europäischer Studiengang und das war mit Sicherheit auch in Zusatzbonus,
dadurch dass ich verschiedene Sprachen spreche komme ich natürlich in dieser internationalen Umgebung hier Teresa sehr gut zurecht.
Was heißt das Werkstoffwissenschaftler.
Werkstoffwissenschaftler bedeutet das Studium ist eine Mischung aus Physik Chemie und Ingenieurswissenschaften.
Unterschied darauf ab neue Werkstoffe Materialien zu entwickeln wie z.b. Leichtbauwerkstoffe das war mein Promotionsthema Leichtbauwerkstoffe die man auch für die Raumfahrt einsetzen kann.
Das war jetzt Aluminiumschaum verbunde die an der Oberfläche noch einmal veredelt waren mit spritzschichten.
Und das war in Aachen.
Das war in Aachen RWTH.
RWTH das heißt so aus der Ferne hat man sich ohnehin schon so ein bisschen mit Raumfahrt beschäftigt.
Ja als Wissenschaftler oder als Ingenieur damals er um Werkstoffe zu entwickeln aber weniger jetzt um selbst zu fliegen obwohl der erste deutsche Astronaut ulf Merbold oder westdeutsche Astronaut ulf Merbold,
ist ja Physiker von der Ausbildung her aber er hat auch nummeriert in einem Werkstoff wissenschaftlichen Thema.
Das erdachtes kann ich auch.
Ja gut das kann ich auch ich meine das Thema Weltraum beschäftigt er viele und ist faszinierend und hat Jan gelesen habe 2008 die ISA sucht neue Astronauten da wusste ich sofort super das passt.
Oder musstest du es diesen unglaublichen Auswahl.
Genau ein Jahr Auswahl mit sehr vielen Stufen und am Anfang denkt man noch nie sind so viele super Kandidaten dabei das wird vermutlich nicht klappt.
Aber je mehr man dann dem Ende kommt und man ist immer noch dabei dann denkt man am Schluss ja dass das klappt jetzt wirklich.
Aber schon auch eine nervliche Belastung.
Ja besonders ja.
Weil es ist einfach so mein hat eine Chance und wenn ich die verpasse dann ist es gelaufen weil die ist das ja sucht eigentlich so im Schnitt alle 15 Jahre neue Astronauten,
und wenn ich meinen Slot verpasse dann werde ich in 15 Jahren vermutlich zu alt sein.
Glück gehabt.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage wenn man so schaut welche Zukunft.
Hatten die Raumfahrt eigentlich und das war so auf ein bisschen unser Thema heute sein also mal so ein bisschen so eine Einschätzung zu finden was eigentlich noch getan werden muss.
Sag mal so eine Phase der generellen.
Entdeckung des Weltalls überhaupt erstmal zum Mond kommen zum Mars irgendetwas zu schicken das Weltall zu verstehen Instrumente ins All zu schicken um einfach zu begreifen was uns eigentlich,
umgibt auf der anderen Seite hat die Raumfahrt ja auch diese wichtige Aufgabe eigentlich übernommen quasi der Forschung style.de,
Weltwirtschaft zu Reims mal ganz salopp auszudrücken weil vieles von dem was.
Im Orbit quasi entdeckt und erstmalig ausprobiert wird findet ja dann mehrere Jahre später oder vielleicht auch schneller seinen Weg in moderne Herstellungsverfahren,
bitte dreimal ist ein Thema was dich quasi als Materialwissenschaftler ja auch immer schon beschäftigt hat oder.
Absolut aber ich würd es nicht nur so sehen dass alles was im Weltraum entwickelt wird da jetzt später hin,
tägliche Leben dann Einzug hält sondern auch umgekehrt also unsere Wirtschaft ist so dynamisch und damit so viel geforscht auf dem Boden auch dass wir sehr viele interessante Entwicklungen,
vom Boden nehmen und sagen okay das ist was Tolles das können wir auch im Weltraum verwenden jetzt einmal das Beispiel 3D Druck,
das ist ja klar auf dem Boden schon kommerziell einsatzbereit und wir wollen diese Idee,
diese Technologie auch nutzen um eventuell auf anderen Himmelskörpern etwas zu drucken oder auch im Weltraum zu tun.
Hätte den Vorteil und ein bisschen ausführen darf,
jetzt momentan habe ich Raketen mit denen starte ich Satelliten in den Weltraum und ich Satelliten die werden so stabil gebaut zum Teil C massivgebaut damit sie den Staat überstehen er hat das heißt.
Baue diese Satelliten eigentlich viel überdimensionierte als er ist für ihre eigentliche Funktion sein müssten nur damit ich sie.
Den ersten 8 minuten ihrer Lebensdauer sicher in den Weltraum bringen kann würde ich jetzt in der Lage sein einen Satelliten im Weltraum zu bauen dann könnte ich den viel filigraner bauen.
Unter müsste weniger Masse in den Weltraum schießen.
Das wäre dann effizienter ich würde Ressourcen sparen ich könnte mit der gleichen Rakete vielmehr in den Weltraum bringen.
Und die Idee ist zu sehen könnte ich im Weltraum einen Satellit.
Aufbauen oder kann ich den drucken zum Teil und muss noch die elektronischen Komponenten dann zufügen ja also sowas wie ne.
Demontage im Weltraum.
Ist ja schon gemacht worden.
Ist noch nicht gemacht worden wir haben auf der ISS einen 3D Drucker der hat erst einmal in Kunststoff gedruckt habe jetzt in Vorbereitung ist auch einem 3D Drucker der auch Metalle drucken kann.
Von Senta Verfahren.
Ja ich denke das wird ein sinterverfahren sein oder vielleicht auch ein Schmelzdraht Verfahren.
Es gibt da verschiedene Ansätze wenn ich mit dem Pulver Verfahren arbeite dann habe ich natürlich das Problem der Schwerelosigkeit wie kann ich das Pulver ablegen dass das wird mir davon dann müsste ich schon wieder eine Zentrifuge dabei haben,
aber sowohl die westlichen Raumfahrtagentur als auch die chinesische Raumfahrtagentur arbeiten an diesem Thema also in Metall 3D Drucker für den Weltraum ist schon eingeplant für die chinesische Raumstation.
Was könnte man damit bauen.
Man könnte damit z.b. Ersatzteile bauen auf der ISAF haben wir momentan das Problem will ich es meinen,
dass wir über 70 verschiedene Typen Ventilatoren haben das fängt an mit dem Ventilator für die Computer bis hin zu anderen Punkten die gekühlt werden müssen alle diese Ventilatoren,
wenn es kaputt gehen müssen ersetzt werden ansonsten überhitzter System das heißt ich muss da 70 verschiedene Ventilatoren immer gelagert haben.
3 4 facher Ausführung.
Genau ob die jetzt nun gebraucht wird oder nicht weiß ich nicht aber wenn ich jetzt sage ich habe ein tolles Verfahren mit dem ich mir so ein Ventilator schnell drücken kann.
Dann kann ich einfach die Ressourcen sparen den Platz sparen und ich muss nicht ständig soviel Lagerhaltung betreiben und ja Ersatzteile oben haben die vielleicht nie verwendet werden.
Gibt's denn so viele so vergleichsweise simple Dinge für die das so in Frage kommen würde.
Ja es gibt schon eine Vielzahl an simplen Sachen ein Beispiel wäre ja auch jetzt aus Apollo 13 Mission also das wäre total unspannend gewesen diese Apollo 13 disaster wenn ich da,
in 3D Drucker dabei gehabt hätte weil damals war die Fragestellung ich habe ich habe eine Kartusche.
Die passt nur einen runden Behälter aber ich brauche jetzt einem anderen Modul in einer Kartusche für den eckigen Behälter und das ganze Drama war ja wie kann ich nach dakta bauen von rund auf eckig.
Heutzutage würde ich einfach ein File hochladen ja genau und genau.
Heutzutage bin ich einfach in File hochladen und wird mir dann Adapter drucken und ja das Ganze wäre dann einfach gelöst sehr schnell.
Also in 3D Drucker gehört für die Exploration absolut auf unsere Packliste nicht nur für den Weltraum,
sondern auch später wenn ich mal auf den Mond Fliege oder Richtung Mars Pflege ums mal vereinfacht darzustellen wenn ich mit heutiger Technologie Richtung Maas Fliege 500 Tage hin und zurück die schnellste Reisemöglichkeit dann brauche ich schon zuviel.
Treibstoff und Vorräte für meine Astronauten dass ich die Rakete vollgestopft hätte.
Und hätte wenig Platz für Wissenschaft dabei das heißt ich würde so eine lange Reise machen und könnte am Mast nur sehr wenig aktiv erforschen.
Weiter bei der Platz fehlt viel intelligenter wäre es ich würde eine Technologie vorausschicken die dort auf dem,
Master Ressourcen nutzt mir vielleicht eine kleine Station baut oder auch Ressourcen aus dem Haushalt auszieht so etwas wie Wasser aus dem Wasser kann ich ein Treibstoff machen sodass ich dann.
Nur mit den Sachen hin Fliege zu Maß die ich definitiv für den Hinflug brauche und dort finde ich dann alles für meinen Rückflug dann könnte ich vielmehr Wissenschaft machen.
Und diese Technologie die möchte ich natürlich nicht zum allerersten Mal auf dem Mars ausprobieren weil es wäre blöd wenn ich da er sich mal 500 Tage Reise vor mir habe und stelle dort Festool das klappt nicht so wie ich mir Sorge.
So pretty so eine kleine Welt Raumfabrik würde man es als erstes hinschicken.
Ja genau genau.
Oder erstmal eine ein Gerät was eine Weltraum verbaut.
Anrechnung Fabrik hört sich wieder groß an Sonne.
Medi fabriziert halt Sachen also für den Name ist nicht ganz falsch.
In 3D Drucker würde ich es meinen der mir aus den Master eine kleine Station baut und das Abfallprodukt gewinne ich die Feuchtigkeit.
Aus dieser aus diesem maasland und diese Feuchtigkeit kann ich Wasser herstellen.
Unter dieses Wasser ist im Endeffekt ja Raketentreibstoff Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff und Ausatemluft.
Also das ist das Grundprinzip diese Technologie die muss auf einmal funktionieren.
Ansonsten brauche ich da gar nicht hin zu fliegen damit sie funktioniert müssen wir die testen und das können wir wunderbar auf dem Mond machen und deswegen der große Schritt wir wollen auf den Mond wir wollen dort die ganze Technologie für eine dauerhafte Präsenz.
Auf dem Mars später einmal testen ausprobieren und wirklich aus reifen lassen.
Bevor wir dann die Teilenummer drauf eingehen würde ich ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen auf die Metaebene einsteigen und erstmal noch mal so hinterfragen.
Was brauchen wir denn weil ich mein das ist ja zum schon bisschen so ein Selbstzweck na das ist quasi so man hat beschlossen man will dahin und wann man will da irgendwas machen und wie kann man das tun und hier gibt es Technologie mit dem man das besser machen kann wo steht sie auch immer erstmal so die Frage,
brauchen wir eigentlich und warum tun wir das.
Als als Mensch brauche ich ganz einfach ich brauche einen Platz an dem ich mich sicher aufhalten kann da draußen herrscht Weltraumstrahlung und es gibt auch Mikrometeoriten auf dem Mond das heißt ich brauche irgendwie so ein.
Ich warte noch eine Metaebene nach vorne was sind soziale überhaupt die.
Die Fragen und die Probleme die wir jetzt überhaupt erstmal lösen wollen weil da Mond ist so wie interessant drücke bestimmte Menge Leute die Wunder ganz gerne mal hin fliegen so aber das kann ja kein Selbstzweck sein aber muss ja.
Nee da gib mich die folgende wissenschaftliche Ziele.
Eine der großen Grundfragen der ESA ist ja gibt es Leben außerhalb der Erde das ist eine ganz große philosophische Frage hat die Menschen schon immer,
beschäftigt und wir wissen der Mond ist es hat sich ja nie Leben beherbergt da müssen wir weiterhin Ausfliegen der Maas es wird vermutet dass der Mars mal,
Feuchtwangen US-Wahl riesige Wasservorkommen an der Oberfläche hatte Wasser wird assoziiert mit Leben das heißt der Mars ist ein Kandidat wo wir nach Spuren von.
Existierenden oder vergangenen Leben noch suchen kann.
Das ist der Grund warum wir Richtung was fliegen wollen um diese Frage gibt es Leben außerhalb der Erde zu beantworten.
Befinde zumindest mal in die Zehen zusammen so.
Die große philosophische Fragen dann haben wir aber auch noch wirklich andere Fragen die wir vom Mond aus noch erledigen können auf dem Mond möchten Wissenschaftler ein Radioteleskop aufstellen weil auf dem Mond habe ich keine Atmosphäre.
Die Erdatmosphäre schluckt nämlich gewisse Frequenzbereiche die für die Radio Astronomen sehr spannend sind und Informationen liefern über die ganz frühen Phasen.
Entstehung unseres Universums kurz nach dem Urknall das heißt Mond ist auch eine wissenschaftliche Plattform,
dann nutzen wir den Mond auch um Modelle zu erstellen Modelle wie ist unser Sonnensystem entstanden wie alt ist sind die gewissen Himmelskörper auf dem Mond funktioniert das dermaßen dass wir sagen okay.
In dieser Bereich sind so und so viele Krater.
Und dann gehe ich in diesen Bereichen ein nehme Gesteinsproben und sage okay dieses Areal ist 3 Milliarden Jahre alt sonst stelle ich eine Korrelation auf ihrem Erkrather ich habe desto älter ist ein Gebiet und diese.
Diese masterkurve will ich mal nennen die ich für den Mond entwickelt habe.
Wie verwende ich dann auch um zu sagen was die Region auf Maß ist so alt die Region auf die Tanne so und so alt einfach indem ich rad erzähle.
Ja so ist es so machen dass die Wissenschaftler hört sich jetzt ein bisschen trivial an aber.
Ja klar weil umso länger die Fläche so.
Zu mehr ist da hat eingeschlagen genau und der Mond ist tot an der Oberfläche der hat sich nicht verändert die gleiche Einschlags Menge an Weiher auf der Erde aber die Erde ist aktiv.
Die Erdoberfläche verändert sich immer wieder deswegen finden auf der Erde.
Die doch immer noch das Kaugummipapier von den amerikanischen Astronauten rum.
Genau aber ich meine hier in Deutschland haben noch den Rieskrater aber so viel mehr Krater die wir untersuchen können finden wir hier nicht.
Das heißt die Raumfahrt ist eigentlich immer noch eine beim alten Ziel sozusagen die Antwort auf die Frage nach dem Leben dem Universum und dem ganzen Rest.
Mich ändern ich mein das geht jetzt sogar immer weiter wir entdecken immer mehr Exoplaneten also Planeten außerhalb unseres eigenen Sonnensystems und die Frage ist natürlich gibt's dort einen erdähnlichen Planeten.
Und gibt's dort wenn es ein erdähnliche Planet ist vielleicht auch sogar erdähnliche Lebewesen.
Gibt's vielleicht noch mal so etwas wie Menschen sowie und wie wir die vielleicht früher angefangen haben ihre Entwicklung und sogar viel weiter sind als wir also ich finde das ein super spannendes Thema.
Ja na das ist zweifelsohne also dermaßen quasi jetzt das Naheliegende nasil.
Birnen das Horizont Ziel ja.
Orizon Ziel.
Also ein Ziel was wir,
so im Rahmen unseres Lebens vielleicht jetzt erreichen können mit bemannte Raumfahrt weit über den Mars werden wir es vermutlich mit den jetzigen Antrieben nicht schaffen da müssen wir viel bessere schnellere Antriebe,
um viel weiter in den Weltraum zu fliegen aber auch das wird kommen irgendwann.
Wollte der Maße der Bitte da noch genug Spielraum zur also die man muss ja nur kurz die Science-Fiction schauen die Ideen sind ja quasi alle da das auszufüllen wird wahrscheinlich paar Jahrzehnte dauern.
Und das große Interesse in dem Maß hat eigentlich zu dieser wieder Entdeckung.
Des Mondes Gefühl kann man sagen der Mond schien ja so ein bisschen aus dem Spiel zu sein mit dem Wort irgendwie keiner mehr spielen aber man jetzt irgendwie oben und.
Ja das auch mal bisschen politisch motiviert also die Wissenschaftler wollten immer wieder zurück auf den Mond ich meinte die ganz spannen wissenschaftlichen Mission waren ja dann noch Apollo 18 19 20 die waren ja schon vorgeplant und dann aber ein,
wann wenn man das Geld lieber für den Vietnamkrieg damals ausgegeben hat,
und politisch motiviert war es auch weil Obama gesagt hat okay dort wo der Bus hin will nämlich Richtung Mond will ich nicht hin fliegen ich gebe ein neues Ziel aus,
jetzt sei mal wieder in anderen Präsidenten der sagt wo der Barmer nicht in will hinwollte will ich nicht hin alles schwingt immer so bisschen hin und her dummerweise.
Ist die ist eine,
langfristige Entwicklung der Weltraumtechnologie nicht im Rahmen von acht Jahren also zwei Legislaturperioden in den USA sinnvoll machbar wir müssen Technologie entwickeln,
Weltraumkapsel und Raketen mit dner viel weiter in den Weltraum fliegen können wir brauchen dann wissen mehr langfristige Planungssicherheit.
Wir sind jetzt auch nicht nur an den Amerikanern.
Nicht nur aber wir Europäer wir haben ja keine eigene Rakete mit der werbemann in den Weltraum fliegen können das heißt wir sind eigentlich per Anhalter.
Richtung durch die Galaxis unterwegs,
wir möchten gern mit den Amerikanern fliegen wir fliegen nach mit den Russen jetzt fragen wir die Chinesen und damit fliegen dürfen denke langfristig und deswegen verfolge ich jetzt auch die aktuellen politischen Entwicklungen sehr mit Interesse,
macron Merkel wollen Europa stärken also mein starker Wunsch wäre lass uns doch mal anfangen in europäisch Symbol.
Zu schaffen indem wir sagen wir wollen auf Augenhöhe mit China mit USA mit Russland mithalten wir wollen auch bemannt.
Von Europa aus in den Weltraum starten.
Zumindest erstmal den Orbit vielleicht in der eigene Raumstation oder mit dem eigenen Vehikel.
Wir erst einmal den erdnahen Orbit erstmal den ersten Schritt schaffen.
Weil die Technik ist ja da immer das was die Amerikaner verwenden wollen kommt aus Europa das ATV was wir auch schon mal ausführlich besprochen wurde ist ja quasi die technische Basis für dieses Vehikel wäre es noch gleich.
Also wir,
gerade die Antriebseinheit den Motor für die Orion Kapsel die Amerikaner entwickeln ja diese schwerlastrakete SLS mit der Richtung Mond und weiter fliegen können auf dieser Rakete sitzt eine neue Kapsel,
die Orion Kapsel und diese Kapsel wird angetrieben mit europäischer Technologie die in Bremen gebaut wird das wäre super können das.
Wir müssen einer Woche essen.
Den Eindruck hat man auch Kuru gewonnen also ich habe voll die Raketenstart verpasst aber ja dann noch einen ausführlichen Tag uns mal diese,
unfassbare Dimension dieses Geländes auch zu vergegenwärtigen und wie viel Leute da an wie vielen Dingen arbeiten und finde sowieso immer,
Sohn springt wenn man um die feststellt was alte ich alles so berücksichtigt und warum sich alles gekümmert werden muss,
Momentum wie mal alle vier Wochen so ein Ding in die Luft schießen zu können.
Aber da merkt man auch die die Expertise ist eigentlich da also man ist jetzt nicht irgendwie unwissend und es fehlt irgendetwas wann ist es am Ende eigentlich im Wesentlichen Sonnen gesamt politischer und gesellschaftspolitischer Wunsch der da sein muss um,
so ein Projekt auch angehen zu können.
Ich würd sogar viel positiver formulieren wir Europäer sind eigentlich führend in der kommerziellen Raumfahrt,
die ganze Zeit gewesen dann steht jetzt natürlich ein ganz starker Druck durch die neuen Anbieter Elon Musk mit SpaceX oder dann auch Jeff Bisons mit dem,
du origin also da deswegen müssen wir auch die Ariane 6 entwickeln einfach um über den Preis langfristig mithalten zu können.
Was jetzt geschieht die Ariane 6 wird demnächst dann auch den Orbit ankratzen und ich hoffe ja auch dieses Programm mal ausfüllen aber darum soll es jetzt nicht gehen.
Komme zurück zu dem Weg den quasi die Raumfahrt jetzt beschreiten muss wir haben also das Fernziel Umschulung Horizont.
Na Horizont wie auch immer auf jeden Fall das Ziel der Maas wird eine Menge Interesse ist aber schwierig ist,
relativ weit weg und vor allem auch mal nicht so mal eben hin und zurück problemlos machen und allein das zurück ist ja auch schon mal ein Problem für sich weil gut vom Mund kommen relativ schnell weg da muss man sicherlich im Wesentlichen einmal kurz abstoßen.
Aber bei Maß ist es halt vergleichbar mit der Erde sprich es gibt mir ganze Menge unbeantwortete Fragen und.
Auch wenn der Mond jetzt vernachlässigt wurde.
Das Interesse am Maß hat jetzt auch den politischen Weg geebnet wieder sich mir den Mond anzunehmen.
Was sind denn jetzt so die Dinge die man jetzt demnächst auf dem Mond tun könnte und sollte um eben eine solche Mars-Mission vorzubereiten.
Ja gut das hatte ich eben schon mal kurz angerissen wir brauchen Technologie Technologie die es uns erlaubt langfristig auf einem Himmelskörper zu bleiben.
Und Ressourcen lieber vor Ort finden die wenn nicht von der Erde einpflegen müssen wann dann wird ihrem Fett unbezahlbar diese Ressourcen auf dem Mars oder auf dem Mond zu nutzen.
Und in sinnvolle Produkte umzusetzen und diese Produkte sind einmal in kleines Haus für die Astronauten damit sie geschützt sind vor der harten Weltraumstrahlung und auch vor den Mikrometeoriten die man mal wieder einschlagen.
Dann brauchen natürlich Energie und ohne Energie können wir nicht zurück Funken und Bilder schicken oder unsere Anlagen betreiben und so Station betreiben also müssen wir Strom erzeugen.
Dann müssen wir für die Phasen der Mond Nacht wo keine Sonne scheint müssen wir die Energie auch speichern können.
Energiespeicher das alles sind Themen die auf der Erde genauso spannend sind Energieerzeugung Energiespeicherung.
Dann brauchen wir Atemluft wir brauchen Trinkwasser.
Und es gibt auch essen also alles Irdische normale menschliche Bedürfnisse und all das müssen wir versuchen auf dem Mond auf dem Mars herzustellen.
Nicht gelingen 100% abzudecken aber will nur 90% abdecken können dann Erspartes natürlich die Stadt Kosten für diese 90%.
Aber du musst es ja jetzt nicht nur interessant weil man dort schon mal was testen kann was man falsch später beim Arzt macht seine ist ja auch als Zwischenlandung Sword eigentlich interessant.
Der Mond wird sogar meiner Meinung nach ein sehr starkes kommerzielles Interesse.
Weil der Mond hat natürlich einen sehr geringen Gravitationspotential als die Erde von daher ist es sinnvoll,
eine Reise zum Mars vom Mond aus zu beginnen das heißt ich stelle es mir vor.
Die Astronauten starten von der Erde fliegen in den Mond Orbit Orbit wird die Rakete noch einmal aufgetankt mit Treibstoff vom Mond.
Und dann fliegen wir dich Thomas weil das ist energetisch viel effizienter im Mond normal.
Zu stoppen noch mal.
Man braucht erstmal nur die Energie um von der Erde weg zu kommen die Tank sie dann quasi leer aber wenn man nach lädt kann man dann quasi.
Ich mal mit derselben Performance durchstarten und die Energie die man also welchem Verhältnis steht denn das zusammen also die Energie die ich brauche um aus der Schwerkraft Feld abzuhauen.
Asi Fluggeschwindigkeit zu erreichen wie.
Wie viel also ist das dieselbe in etwa dieselbe Energie die man dann braucht um noch zum Mars zu fliegen oder sogar noch ist die Strecke dann so leichter bist du nicht.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht so 100% genau sagen aber.
Weiß ja das auf dem Mond habe ich nur 16 Schwerkraft Sohn und um aus diesem 16 Schwerkraft der Erde rauszufliegen brauche ich natürlich auch deutlich weniger Energie also die Fluchtgeschwindigkeit ist deutlich geringer.
Aber wenn man im Orbit ist hat mir ja noch nicht mal das Problem also da muss man ja nur noch einen kleinen Schubs geben um wieder raus zu kommen wollen wir ja nicht auf dem Boden startet.
Ganz genau also vom Mond Orbit aus brauchst du eigentlich dass wir müssen uns die Karte jetzt angucken wie die einzelnen Delta wie sind also die einzelnen Beschleunigung aber es sind deutlich effizienter vom Mond aus noch mal durchzustarten an Richtung Maas.
Also sozusagen auch vorstellbar dass man einzuzahlen Sophia Energieressourcen hat dass man dann eben auch auf dem Markt nicht unbedingt bei Null ankommen sollen.
Gut das sind jetzt da da waren wir ein über Mission Details zu sprechen das einfach das hängt immer davon ab wie groß ist meine Rakete wie viel Masse nehme ich mit und so weiter und.
Aber so oder so der Mond ist ist eigentlich ein wichtiges logistisches Element in in einer solchen.
Sogar effizienter Satelliten die im Tier stationären Orbit fliegen wenn ich diese wieder auftanken möchte ist es effizienter dies vom Mond her vom Mond Orbit zu machen.
Obwohl das von der Distanz sehr viel weiter weg ist also wir reden jetzt von 36000 km Höhe über der Erde des geostationäre Umlaufbahn.
Der Mond ist 400.000 km weg aber es ist energetisch günstiger sage ich mal 370 000 km vom Mond kommen Richtung bierstation Erdumlaufbahn zu fliegen dort aufzutanken als das von der Erde aus zu machen.
Aber nur wenn er Treibstoff HR vom Mond kommt.
Genau nur wenn er von dort aus kommt sicher.
Reichen die Ressourcen des Mondes dafür.
Ja auf dem Mond gibt es riesige Vorkommen an Wasser Altmann hat abgeschätzt dass ich glaube 100 Millionen Tonnen.
Wassereis in der Polarregion liegen müssten den Tiefen Quadern die Frage ist natürlich sind diese Wassereis vollkommen zugänglich wenn ich mir das jetzt mal angucken diese gratis sind sehr tief.
Und haben sehr steile Abhänge und wir haben mit die kältesten Temperaturen in diesem Grad an.
In unserem Sonnensystem darstellt natürlich enorme technologische Herausforderung an die Ausrüstung die ich da mitbringen muss um erst einmal diese Ressourcen.
Dazugewinnen und aus dem Mund extrahieren andererseits wenn ich jetzt nicht zu viel Wassereis rausbringen möchte sondern ich möchte nur einmal sagen ich gewinne so viel,
Wasser um eine Station zu betreiben mit sechs Astronauten dann kann ich das auch direkt aus dem aus dem Mond Sand machen.
Gewisse Anteile des Mondes enthalten sehr viel Oxid und bei der wenn ich jetzt ein 3D Druck Prozess Einsätze.
Drücke mir daraus Mondsteine aus Sand dann gewinnt dich als Abfallprodukt dadurch Sauerstoff.
Und wenn ich ein bisschen Wasserstoff mitbringen was ja deutlich leichter ist als Salz der Sauerstoff X Factor 16 dann kann ich,
da aus diesem Prozess dann Wasser gewinnen und dieses Wasser ist im Trinkwasser bzw Sauerstoff kann ich dann auch wieder verwenden einfach zum als Atemluft.
Woraus macht man in den Treibstoff mit dem man.
Treibstoff für die Ariane Rakete fliegt mit Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff.
Das ließe sich dann auf diesem Wege alles vor Ort mit Hilfe der Sonne produzieren in brauchbaren Mengen auch.
Ganz genau sicher und Laufbahn Mengen aber die Prozesse existieren noch nicht also wären noch nicht die ausgereifte Technologie dafür.
Na da wären wir ja gerade über die ich meine das ohnehin spannend,
auch einfach mal ein bisschen darüber zu reden was es einfach noch gar nicht gibt's klar dass nicht alles realisiert werden würde aber dann wäre ja auch nicht dahin gekommen wo man heute ist wenn man sich immer nur an den Realitäten des damaligen technologischen Standes Gehalt.
Sicher es geht immer weiter also ich bin sicher in der Zukunft werden die die neuen Shell und Exxon mobile das werden die Leute sein die auf dem Mond Treibstoff herstellen können als da liegt in der riesiges Geschäftsfeld noch wach.
Asam den Mond sozusagen jetzt erstmal als.
Potentiellen Energie Generator sozusagen verortet man weiß wie man da hinkommt.
Mandala schonmal man kennt das irgendwie halbwegs und ich denke es gibt jetzt auch für die Überzeugung wenn man in der Lage ist mir egal Roboter auf dem Mars durch die Gegend fahren zu lassen dann ist das auf dem Mond noch nicht mal so ein großes Problem.
Es ist nicht in unlösbares Problem aber es ist gibt definitiv noch viele Sachen die wir lösen müssen also wenn ich an den Strahlenschutz denke und Emmas Reise die kann ich mit dem jetzigen Strahlenschutz nicht so durchführen,
ganz einfach die Reise würde viel zu lange dauern und wie hast du Noten werden in unserer Kapsel einfach zu lange,
der hat ein Strahlung ausgesetzt dürfen Gesundheitsrisiko also entweder müssen wir die Kapseln starker abschirmen dann werden sie wieder schwerer.
Der Flug dorthin wird ineffizienter.
Oder ich muss neue Verfahren entwickeln wie ich einfach schneller Pflege damit ich weniger Zeit der Strahlung ausgesetzt bin oder ich finde bessere Materialien oder bessere Prozesse,
um eine Abschirmung der Strahlung zu erzielen während des Fluges das ist eins dann waren wir natürlich in den 70er oder,
69 bis 72 dann in dieser Zeit auf dem Mond und hatten dort auch Exploration durchgeführt aber wenn ich mir angucken so einen Raumanzug damals wurde genutzt für 1 bis 2 EWS als außenbord Einsätze.
Und diese aggressive Mond Sand der zu scharfkantig und so so fine pulverich der setzt sich schon in die Kleidung in der Kleidung fest sodass nach 3 Außenborder einsetzen.
Die Astronauten schon Probleme hatten dass diese Anzüge belastet waren die die Dichtungsringe die waren schon nicht mehr 100% perfekt.
Weil es gibt ja keinerlei Gezeiten Vintage die quasi diese Partikel hätte rundschleifen können so wie wir das von der Erde.
Ganz genau ganz genau und das.
Durch den ständigen Beschuss mit sonnenpartikel wird dieses Material auch immer immer sehr sehr scharfkantig immer wieder aufgebrochen ja.
Das heißt wir müssen Prozesse entwickeln sowas wie ein Lotuseffekt was wir jetzt schon da verwenden auch für Erzieher.
Nano coating.
Nano coating genau.
Oder auch Gebäudefassaden die selbstreinigend sind genauso etwas brauchen wir auch für Astronauten Anzüge das heißt wie reinigt sich mein Astronautenanzug immer wieder selbst sodass,
er nicht durch den Mund Staub dauerhaft belastet wird und vielleicht nur zweimal benutzt werden kann.
Weil das ist dann auch dann habe ich auch keine sinnvolle explorations Technologie ich möchte mehr als dreimal über den Mond laufen mit dem Anzug.
Also geht das jetzt mehr so in keramische Oberflächen oder kleine Nanobots die auf der Oberfläche alles frei putzen.
Ja ich denke ihr vielleicht über elektromagnetische Säuberung dass wir versuchen da diese Strahlung die diese Partikel die sie abgelagert haben auf Zulagen aufzuladen und die wieder ab zu stoßen bei der.
Könnte eine Methode sein aber da muss geforscht werden.
Ja darauf will ich ein bisschen die neuesten also was was müssen jetzt eigentlich alles erfinden damit wir meine coole Marslandung mit Astronauten haben.
Also wir brauchen einen sehr tollen oder verschiedene sehr tolle 3D Drucker die aus dem Mond und dem Maßband muss Mondstein bauen können ja damit kann ich mir dann eine Station aufbauen.
Diese Station Platy.
Wie baue ich diese Steine zusammen das natürlich auch noch mal eine Frage oder kann ich dass diese ganze Station diese Fülle in einem Stück drucken.
Wie gewinne ich sauerstoff wie Gewinn ich Wasserstoff aus den Mond Ressourcen da gibt es auch schon Ansätze die momentan in Spanien verfolgt werden Mac gibt's den in ganz große Sonnenfarm in Almeria.
Und dort wird Sonnenenergie gebündelt und dieser gebündelte Strahl wird fokussiert auf eine Fläche von ca mehr der Fläche einer 1 € Münze,
allein durch Sonnenkraft erreiche ich dann einen Strahl der über 2000 Grad heißes,
dreist mit diesem Strahl kann ich sogar Stahl durchschneiden und diesen Strahl.
Kann ich nun gezielt über Mond Sandras dann lassen und dann ist es ähnlich wie in.
Metallpulver 3D Druck wo ich dann in Laserstrahl über Metallpulver das dann lasse und baue mir sind mir dadurch in Bauteil zusammen.
Wie dick ist in dieser Regulierer Mondstaub.
Der ist wirklich im im im submillimeter Bereich.
Ich meine wie tief also wie wie wie.
Wie viel wie tief in den Boden Gitter.
Wie tief sind man da ein.
Also einsinken tut man nicht sehr viel das haben die Astronauten ja getestet.
Also wie weit kann man quasi geboren und findet nur diesen Staub bevor man etwas.
Ja ich glaube das ist in der Größenordnung 10 bis 30 m müsste auf jeden Fall nur dieser Decollete zu finden.
So viel also kann man sich zum kompletten SUV raus sind dann zusagen.
Ja das könnte man das könnte man definitiv.
Erstmal lokaler unterschiedlicher also das ist wir haben ja diese Flachland Regionen die Marias und dann haben wir auch die Hochland Regionen und sicherte das muss man natürlich auch noch mal ortsspezifisch dann abklären.
Okay aber es ist jetzt nicht nur so eine dünne Staubschicht und da drunter ist irgendwie,
Stein weil ich glaube das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein Bild was also ich zumindest bis eben gerade noch so ein bisschen im Kopf hatte aber das was quasi dann so der einzige Staub Wüste ist in der man im Prinzip dann auch nennenswert in die Tiefe gehen kann weil da,
bedeutet ja man muss ja dann oder ob ich den auch gar nicht erst groß und was aufbauen dann meine tatsächlich das einfach so wie es ist.
Ganz klar und auch noch mal das Potenzial darzulegen ich hier,
wenn der ja im Nachbarschaft vom Astronauten Zentrum in der Traglufthalle aufstellen und in diese Traglufthalle hinein werden wir in der Größenordnung ich glaube 900 Tonnen Mond Saturnmond,
ähnliches Material einfüllen Eintritt dieses Mond Sandes hat schon genug.
Potential wenn ich es nutzen würde mit so einem solchen 3D Prozess und könnte ein Sauerstoff rausziehen um einem Mondstation mit sechs Astronauten für ein Jahr lang mit Sauerstoff zu versorgen.
Das heißt also es ist genügend eigentlich Sauerstoff und und Material sind nutzbar das Material vorhanden.
All das ist das Luna Projekt ich das richtig sehe also dass du dich blicken wir gerade hier aus dem Fenster auf die Fläche wo steht warum ist das eine Traglufthalle warum.
Ja das geht einfach viel schneller wir sind ja in Deutschland da ist ein Gebäude Antrag sehr mit Happy Bürokratie verbunden,
als wir angefangen haben Mondforschung hier zu initiieren wussten wir noch nicht wären die Ressourcen bereitgestellt das ist ja bei der ESA immer so Förderzeitraum von 3 bis 4 Jahren wo Gelder bereitgestellt werden,
und wir hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt als wir angefangen haben noch kein richtiges explorations oder Mondprogramm deswegen müssen wir mit einem.
Ansatz daran gehen so eine Traglufthalle ist ja wird auf der Tennisplätze benutzt ist deutlich schneller aufzubauen.
Unterlack absolut für diese Zwecke wir führen diese Traglufthalle dann mit Sand mit Mondstaub und können dort dann unsere Mond Außeneinsätze üben.
Wie wird heute man diesen Mondstaub bei den gibt es auch nicht so bei Amazon zu kaufen.
Ja der kommt hier aus der Nähe aus der Eifel das ist vulkanischer Sand der von der Struktur her so ähnlich ist wie der Mond sind immer bei den Apollo-Missionen gefunden hatten auch chemisch ähnlich aufgebaut.
Nee das scharfkantige haben wir da leider nicht ganz aber das ist natürlich ein Problem deswegen können wir.
Sehr viele Sachen testen in unserer neuen Mondbasis Jahr in Köln,
aber gewisse Sachen müssen wir mit anderen Material noch mal Test und für diese für dieses Problem,
wie kann ich die Belastung der Mode Anzüge oder der Damen Anzüge mit diesem scharfkantigen Sand testen da fahren wir immer noch keine Lösung für.
Vielleicht meine Tonne alte Rasierklingen rein raspeln oder.
Er hat diesen dann wieder leicht zu scharfkantig.
Ja und wann soll es hier entstehen Luna.
Ja das ist eigentlich schon so dass wir diese Traglufthalle haben wir können die nur noch nicht aufstellen weil es da aus Naturschutz Gründen noch zu einer Verzögerung kommt wir haben da,
geschützte Eidechsen genau in dieser Fläche und Ende des Jahres wird dann hoffentlich das Gebäude Anfang nächsten Jahres dann aufgestellt inbetriebgenommen.
Ist das ein Projekt dass dir der oder ist das.
Ist ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt zwischen Esel dem astronautenzentrum und DLR.
Wird aber offen sein für alle Vorschau.
Die Interesse daran haben in Europa und auch weltweit wir möchten hier etwas ganz Neues machen und zwar wird die ESA in Zusammenarbeit mit dla hier eine Plattform zur Verfügung stellen.
Und die Nutzung dieser Plattform wird kostenfrei möglich sein das heißt alle alle Gruppen nicht jetzt nur Raumfahrtagentur sondern auch Vorschau oder auch.
Seebad Initiativen die etwas tolles zu bieten haben können hier Forschungszeit beantragen Kanada sagen ey wir würden ganz gerne was machen und wir prüfen das und wenn das passt zu dem Thema was wir gerade verfolgen dann darf da jeder rein.
Also Mond Roboter testen etc.
Absolut sind alle herzlich willkommen.
Aber im Wesentlichen ist es eigentlich so eine lunara Sandkasten fürstenau.
Nicht nur nicht nur weil in Zukunft also zu Apollo Zeiten hat mir natürlich nur Astronaut,
Nanterre eine Robbe auf dem die Gefahren sind aber in Zukunft wird es eine Mensch Maschine Kombination sein wir werden auf den Mond gehen auf Maß fliegen und werden dort zusammen mit Robotern arbeiten,
das heißt wir brauchen auch die Unterstützung von den Fachleuten die hier Roboter und Traube entwickeln.
Ja das eine ganze Menge in Bewegung auf dem Markt hat sich ja auch schon angesprochen.
Finanzamt auch so vor so einer neuen Phase der Raumfahrt wo der kommerzielle Anteil sehr viel größer sein wird Basics ist schon gefallen in der Name dass es natürlich.
Erstmal offensichtlich dass ich quasi der Rainer Staats und Raketen Betrieb schon extrem kommerzialisiert hat aber gerade auch so mit dieser,
mit den Mitteln Potenzial Energiegewinnung gegebenenfalls Ihre Unterstützung geostationärer Satelliten oder ander andere Objekte entstehen ja hier ganz neue Märkte die ist ja so voll einfach noch gar nicht gab.
Siehst du das so mit lachenden oder weinendes auge.
Ja ich freue mich darüber absolut weil dadurch dass diese kommerziellen Anbieter jetzt auf den Markt gekommen sind entstand auch net normal zurück.
Nenndruck für die etablierten Weltraumagentur etwas zu tun effizienter zu arbeiten in Europa sehen wir das dadurch dass die Ariane 6 jetzt 50% günstiger sein soll er hat sie Ariane-5 das kommt ja,
jedem zugute sowohl dem Steuerzahler der das finanziert aber auch den Nutzern die dann etwas Neues in den Weltraum fliegen können.
Vielleicht rechnet sich eine Technologie,
erst wenn die Stadt Kosten deutlich günstiger werden und das sehen wir jetzt wir sehen plötzlich das ganz neue Ideen,
vorkommen Konstellation in den Weltraum zu fliegen diese Konstellation die man in der Vergangenheit einfach nicht denkbar,
weil das zu teuer war diese Raketen zu stark.
Ja das Thema komme ich auch bei uns hat schon mal aufgenommen die Gelegenheit vielleicht noch mal 12 Sendung anzusprechen unter anderem hatte ich ja hier auch mit Karsten Becker gesprochen von den part time scientists ihm aus Berlin die damals noch in dem Kontext der den.
Google Luna Preis.
Bernina Express.
Preis genau das Heerlager mittlerweile eingestellt wurde ohne das wird die etwas losgegangen ist trotz alledem hat das eine ganze Menge los getreten und hast diese Firmen gehen nicht weg die wollen natürlich ihre Projekte auf dem einen oder anderen Wege dann doch noch umgesetzt sehen,
und das ist ja absehbar dass wir dann ganz neuen Konstellationen arbeiten wo,
dann Prinzip ja aber auch die arbeit Theresa dann an die auch so ein ganz neue Basisgruppen wird.
Sicher die ESA hat dann ganz plötzlich jetzt auch Konkurrenz bekommen aus dem privaten Sektor aus dem kommerziellen Sektor,
ich sehe jetzt z.b. SpaceX technologisch gesehen Felde abdecken kann welches dieser nicht mehr abdecken kann wie z.b. bemannte Raumfahrt zu machen das heißt eine Firma.
Dann eigentlich technologisch mehr als ganz Europa durch die europäische Raumfahrtagentur machen kann und das finde ich einerseits ein bisschen besorgniserregend.
Denke da müssen wir mithalten wir müssen zumindest auf Augenhöhe bleiben anders als finde ich es natürlich auch wieder toll das jetzt.
Zeig mal Ideen realisiert werden,
von Privat Initiativen die vielleicht in institutionellen Rahmenbedingungen,
eigentlich nie umgesetzt würden einfach weiter zur disruptiv sind da so einfach zu innovativ also ich freue mich da auch dass da so ein bisschen Unruhe in das ganze reinkommt,
weil es zwingt das ganze Feld so bisschen dynamischer zu reagieren.
Was her auf jeden Fall auch ein bisschen Unruhe ins Spiel gebracht hat und auch neue Konstellation eröffnet,
dann schon kurz an ist die Rolle die China künftig in der Weltraumfahrt übernehmen wird und sicherlich auch,
man hat sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnt an die internationale Kooperation vor allem zwischen den Amerikanern,
den Russen Europäern und den Japanern China will jetzt weit voran und hat ja eigentlich auch einiges geleistet in den letzten Jahrzehnten erste kleine Raumstation gestartet jetzt II und,
wo sind die Chinesen jetzt und wo wollen die hin und wie kann man sich nur eine globale Kooperation wie sie jetzt schon existiert in Zusammenarbeit mit den Chinesen vorstellen.
Also China hat riesige Fortschritte gemacht in Bereiche Raumfahrt sie machen wenige Staats Rahmen bemannte Raumfahrt sehr viele Starts im Bereich Satelliten.
Sie haben bisher zwei Module hoch geschickt für die bemannte Raumfahrt ist erst ist jetzt gerade wieder eingetreten wieder unkontrollierter Wiedereintritt zum Glück.
Immo abgestürzt wo niemand zu Schaden kam ziel ist es.
Im nächsten Jahr das Kernmodul der neuen Weltraumstation zu starten.
Bis 20 22 möchte dann China eine eigene kleine Weltraumstation aufgebaut haben die wird ungefähr so eine Größenordnung haben.
Die mir Station die chinesische Station wird so ca 60 Tonnen an Gewicht betragen die ISS als Vergleich hat über 400 Tonnen also eine ganz andere Größenordnung,
unten.
China möchte eigentlich genau das gleiche erreichen was Russland und die USA bisher erreicht haben das heißt erst einmal eine dauerhafte Präsenz im erdnahen Orbit.
Stadtforschung machen in der Raumstation dann geht China auch dazu über neue Länder einzuladen.
Auf der eigenen Station mitzuarbeiten das erinnert mich so wissen dann das interkosmos Programm was die Sowjetunion damals gemacht hat in den 80er Jahren.
Und später dann auch über diese Spaceshuttle wurden auch westliche Länder eingeladen Astronauten mit dem amerikanischen Gefährt dann mit fliegen zu lassen.
Ist interkosmos dann das was den sigmund Jähn auch in den Orbit gebracht.
Ganz genau das war ganz genau und,
China hatte z.b. auch Abkommen mit dem mit den Vereinten Nationen das heißt alle Länder die Interesse haben Astronauten zur chinesischen Raumstation zuschicken können das über die Vereinten Nationen dann sozusagen vermitteln lassen,
wir Europäer.
Sind seit 2012 im Gespräch mit den chinesischen Kollegen vom chinesischen astronautenzentrum ich selbst war,
Track von Anfang an mit dabei und ich weiß schon mehrfach in China und letztes Jahr gab es das allererste training von nichts wenn nicht chinesischen Astronaut.
Mit chinesischen Astronauten zusammen das war dann Samantha cristoforetti und ich hatten dort ein zweiwöchiges survival-training auf See.
Das war sehr spannend das war sehr professionell durchgeführt die chinesischen Kollegen sind alle super motiviert und ich denke der hat Flecken aus für die Raumfahrt wie das von,
von den Kosmonauten oder von den amerikanischen Astronauten und auf arbeit Ebene gibt's da einfach nur.
Die Sprachbarriere das haben wir aber auch bei Russisch zum Teil auch mit japanisch oder auch mit dem Englischen aber ansonsten sind das eigentlich Raumfahrer yabeat wie wir selbst.
Und.
Sehen dass wir das ganze auch politisch in den Rahmen führen sodass China in dieses ayses consortium aufgenommen werden.
Das wird ja von amerikanischer Seite aus blockiert.
Pizza Hardliner politisch die nicht möchten dass die Chinesen da Zugang zu ISAF bekommen,
aber ich denke Richtung Mond wird das ganze noch mal komplexer werden und später dich nochmals noch komplexer das können wir nur als Menschheit gesamt,
angehen und dann müssen wir China mit ins Boot aufnehmen und nach neue,
spiele auf dem Markt wie z.b. Korea hat interessen der bemannten Raumfahrt die.
Aus der arabischen Regionen gibt es Bestrebungen eigenes Astronauten Kur aufzubauen Indien ist dabei bemannte Raumfahrt zu entwickeln also da ist ja viel Aktivität.
Das kann ich nur kurz sagen.
Die ISS ist jetzt erstmal bis 20:24 Uhr verlängert worden.
Ja ist ja schon länger bis 24-24 finanziert jetzt gerade ist ja die Diskussion was machen wir nach 24.
Die Amerikaner möchten das dann ganz gerne in kommerzielle Hände überführen damit sie einfach ihre Ressourcen bündeln können um sich besser auf den Mond zu konzentrieren.
Da gab es eine Menge Skepsis bei dem Kommentar.
Ja genau ich bin auch sehr skeptisch ich denke die Eis es wird sicher noch bis 20:28 Uhr betrieben werden kann sie aus Ingenieurs Sicht auch ohne Probleme.
Doch auch sicher aber ich meine 20-28 ist 30 Jahre alt die Station wurde irgendwann mal Design für eine gewisse Lebensdauer.
30 Jahren wird der Aufwand vielleicht zu nehmen.
Die Systeme frisch zu halten sicher zu halten da muss man einfach dann noch mal sich alle Details Probleme angucken und sagen okay.
Ab wann rentiert es sich nicht mehr die Stationen zu.
Ab wann ist es günstiger wegzuwerfen was Neues aufzubauen sowie bei einem alten Auto irgendwann ist es einfach zu teuer das zu warten dann ist es günstiger neues aus.
Aber die Antwort auf diese Frage kennt man eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Ja gut.
Hat sowas ja noch nicht gemacht.
Man hat es nicht gemacht und es gibt ja noch die große Frage wie bringe ich dieses große Biester wieder runter oder was mache ich mit dem ja.
Ja
Also ich rede von 400 Tonnen die da um die Erde fliegen und es gibt Studien wie man die ISAF wieder eintreten lassen kann aber die Eis essen wird dann irgendwann auseinanderbrechen.
Dann entsteht wahrscheinlich einen einen Teppich an Weltraumschrott,
die vielleicht nicht mehr so kontrolliert in den Pazifik abgestützt werden lassen kann wie man das normalerweise macht mit diesem kleinen Kapseln.
Heißt dann müssen die Ingenieure auch noch mal bisschen die Herzschmerz einstecken wie kann ich diese Station sicher ja wieder eintreten lassen verglühen lassen.
Ist doch nicht drüber nachgedacht worden.
Da ist drüber nachgedacht und es gibt Arbeitsgruppen die beschäftigen sich mit diesem Thema aber auch hier gibt's noch offene Fragen z.b. wissen wir noch nicht 100% wie verhält sich.
Unsere Atmosphäre in dem Bereich 30 bis 100 km wenn da eine so große Station Wiedereintritt ich kann das nicht perfekt simulieren.
Das ist eine sehr chaotisch Geschichte also in wissenschaftlichen Blick chaotisch dass sie sich irgendwie auseinanderbauen in Einzelteilen wahrscheinlich auch nicht so ohne weiteres.
Sichere ich meine die Russen der russische Teil der Station hat eigene Antriebseinheit.
Aber der westliche Teil der Station wo der mit den Space Shuttles hochgebracht so ich könnte jetzt natürlich hingehen und sagen die neuen kommerziellen,
Kapseln die Amerikaner die können natürlich am westlichen Teil andocken die kann ich wieder dazu nutzen als Antriebseinheit um die Station oder einzelne Segmente gezielt abzubremsen aber ich gehe jetzt wirklich eine Spekulation also,
da müssen Spezialisten oder müssen das simulieren müssen jetzt angucken es ist natürlich machbar aber ist natürlich auch eine Kostenfrage.
Kann ich diese Station dann noch effizienter runterholen.
Wann ist es ohnehin ja auch eine wie ich finde immer stärker aufkommende Debatte die wahrscheinlich auch überfällig ist,
wie sichern wir überhaupt die Zugänglichkeit zum Weltraum ganz unabhängig davon wo man alles noch so hin will muss man dann überhaupt erstmal sicherstellen dass man überhaupt erstmal vom eigenen Planeten noch wegkommt,
das was heute schon an Weltraumschrott so herum fliegt das ist ja nicht ganz unerheblich,
damit sie sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen was passieren würde wenn die ISS auf einmal nicht mehr kontrolliert werden könnte durch irgendein Unfall das wäre dann eine Stunde mittlere Katastrophe wenn irgendein Satellit mit der ISS kollidierte und ist wahrscheinlich auch erstmal für die nächsten 100 Jahre,
mehr zu machen also das Problem ist ja nicht gerade gering und ich habe dir auf den Eindruck dass indem in der Raumfahrt dieses Problem auch schon seit langem.
Verstanden wird man bloß etwas Probleme hat diese Wichtigkeit so in die Öffentlichkeit zu Kommunen.
Genau genau leider investieren die Politiker lieber ja Geld in neue zeig mal forschen neue Satelliten aber in der,
Sauberhaltung des Weltraums sei mal das ist eine langfristige Investition da habe ich kurzfristig keinen Benefit davon und deswegen finden es die Kollegen dann auch so schwer diese Projekt.
Weltraumschrott Vermeidung oder gezielt Entfernung von Weltraumschrott zu finanzieren.
Das ist ein Thema das müssen wir angehen das ist einfach unfassbar weil irgendwann werden wir uns wirklich die verschiedenen Orbitz zumauern mit mit Weltraumschrott.
Und dann ja das wird ein Problem für die nächsten Generation sein insbesondere jetzt wo wir darüber nachdenkt.
Durch kommerzielle Anbieter mega Konstellationen aufzubauen also es gibt jetzt ja Projekt.
Mit mehreren tausend minisatelliten um weltweit Internetzugang zu erstellen Mini Konstellationen das sind das sind Größenordnung von Satelliten die irgendwann mal als Weltraumschrott dann rumfliegen werden.
Das mitzunehmen.
Aber auch hier scheint der kommerzielle move ein wenig aufgeschlossener zu sein ich glaube die letzte Space x-mission hatte schon entsprechende Test,
Mission an Bord um ein paar Technologien ich habe zwei auszuprobieren wie man Weltraumschrott vielleicht wieder eingefangen bekommen könnte.
Sicherheitsgitter Ansätze wie ich das machen kann aber wenn ich immer einlegen hochschicken muss um anderes runterzubringen dann ist es auch nicht das effizienteste.
Wir laden natürlich jetzt noch unter der Phase wo man sich um dieses zurückkommen überhaupt gar keine Gedanken gemacht hat heute ist ja jede Mission von vorne rein selbst verpflichtet Bridge vorzuhalten jetzt kann er sich immer noch passieren wenn,
das Ding einfach mal komplett oder Parabel wird dass man diese Module nicht aktivieren kann aber dann ich hatte ja das Problem schon mal etwas entschärft also hätte man davon,
Unfall angemacht werden sicherlich nicht unbedingt in die Situation in der wir jetzt sind wir das mal so ist mit Müll am,
trotz alledem sind ja auch solche Technologien interessante Herausforderung was ist irgendwie auch ein großes kommerzielles Interesse gibt umso teurer ist wird in den Weltall ins Weltall zu fliegen.
Weil es so vermüllt ist umso größer wird ja dann wiederum auch das Interesse nach entsprechenden interstellaren Putzkolonnen.
Vitaspar.de sahnerolle.
Sicher es gibt die Kollegen die aktiv an diesem,
Bereich dann arbeiten sich angucken wie kann ich einen Satelliten der seinen Lebensende erreicht hat was auf damit zusammenhängt dass ich nicht mehr.
Dabei habe um die Lage des Satelliten zu kontrollieren wie kann ich den deutschen Satelliten z.b. wieder auf.
Ja das sind Projekte die die ESA auch mit untersucht das andere ist natürlich Beobachtung.
Imbiss erdnahen Orbit um zu sehen wo habe ich denn überhaupt welchen Weltraumschrott um sozusagen die Aktiven Satelliten gezielt aus dem Weg zu fahren wenn der Mann Schrott vorbeikommt das machen wir mit der ISAF ja auch.
Gemeinde Ausweichmanöver.
Und das sogar sehr oft ein anderer Ansatz ist wie kann ich gezielt ein Satellit entfernen das heißt ich fahr dahin.
Meinem zweiten Vehikel legt eine Kette dran und schleppt ihn einfach ab sowie ein Abschleppdienst auf der Straße das auch macht das ist jetzt aber wieder um ein Problem weil.
Wenn ich Weltraumschrott entfernen kann dann kann ich auch aktiv sozusagen eine feindliche Übernahme von dem,
anderen Satelliten machen es gibt auch Spionagesatelliten oder vielleicht militärisch motivierte Satelliten das bedeutet wenn ich diese Technologie Entwickler,
dann liefere ich direkt auch wieder den militärmunition zu sagen okay dann müssen wir wieder Gegenmaßnahmen da haben um unsere Satelliten abzusichern.
Auweia habe ich doch kein nachgedacht.
Es ist sehr amerikanische Militärs fordern aktiv nach einer Bewaffnung oder Militarisierung des Weltraums um ihre eigenen Satelliten abzusichern gegen feindliche Angriffe.
Seid kein Teufel an die Wand malen aber es geht ja für mich so ein bisschen wie das Zeitalter der Weltraum Piraterie hat mir auch schon mal im Science Fiction so dass man so sagen Satelliten hoch schickt er dann.
Andere Satelliten erstmal beschlagnahmt und finde sie wieder haben wollt 400 Bitcoin.
Ist durchaus denkbar ja also wenn ich dass diese Technologie benutzen will.
Dualismus von Technologie haben natürlich generell so ne und das bringt das ja nicht davon ab dass man trotzdem noch Lösung finden muss.
Sicher wir brauchen diese Lösung wir müssen den Weltraumschrott entfernen also das ist da führt kein Weg dran vorbei.
Aber es gibt noch nicht so den Königsweg gibt noch nichts wo alle sagen so das ist jetzt die Methode,
gerade wenn man so eine Situation ist müsste das ja eigentlich ein dringender Appell sein dass man hier mal Missionen bräuchte um einfach 10 20 verschiedene Methoden ausprobieren.
Brauchen wir aber mir ist doch noch keinen Königsweg bekannt.
Fischernetze im All.
Ein bisschen wünsch dir was spielen können so aus Astronauten Perspektive man kann sich jetzt einfach mal aussuchen was eigentlich so die nächsten 10 20 Jahren an Missionen losgetreten werden sollte könnte es auch sehr subjektiv sein.
Was würdest du denn denn so vorstellen.
Also ich würde mir wünschen dass Europa wissen selbständiger wird wie es eben angesprochen hatte dass wir als Europäer in eigenen.
Unabhängigen bemannten Zugang zum Weltraum zum erdnahen Weltraum haben dass wir auf Augenhöhe mit den etablierten Spielern mithalten können.
Uns nicht abhängen lassen das ist ganz ganz wichtig dann stelle ich mir vor dass wir dauerhaft langfristig auch eine Plattform im erdnahen Orbit benötigen um die Schwerelosigkeit zu Forschung weiter zu betreiben das heißt wir brauchen.
Entweder tyreis es Verlängerung oder eine Nachfolge der ISAF das kann auch eine Kooperation sein mit den Chinesen oder mit kommerziellen Anbietern für eine solche erdnahen.
Kommerzielle Station gibt's ja auch Ansätze aus den USA dazu.
Könnte man einander iss noch was andocken.
Psychopath andocken ist sogar 1 eine der der Ideen die aus dem kommerziellen sec.
Von aus dem amerikanischen Bereich verfolgt werden ein kommerzielles Modul an der ISAF anzugsocken erst einmal zu lernen.
Wie mache ich Weltraum Betrieb dazu kommerziell und dann später vielleicht wenn die ISAF ihr Lebensende erreicht hat zu sagen dieses neue kommerzielle Modul was vielleicht dann auch schon mittlerweile 234 Module sind.
Abzuzocken und länger zu bezahlen ja also eine Art graduellen Übergangs ist ein und meine Idee dann ist das.
Okay also auch wer auf die Chinesen Amazone optionen so einen Doc rad zu machen.
Ja gut die wollen jetzt die haben ihre eigene Stationen vorbereitet ich denke die wollen ihre Station jetzt einfach durchziehen.
Gleich mal diese 30 Jahre lang erzählt bekommen dass die andern nicht mit ihnen spielen wollen dann machen sie ihr eigenes Ding aber es könnte sich auch wieder ändern.
Genau dann müssen natürlich auch über den erdnahen Orbit hinaus denken das heißt wir wollen Richtung Mond fliegen,
erst einmal in den Mund Orbit hinein dort gibt's dann diese neue Station die aufgebaut werden soll Deep Space Gateway hieß die Scheiße glaube ich Mond,
orbitalum und village ist ja auf dem Boden die Orbitale Mondstation der Name ändert sich auch ständig von dort aus sollen Astronauten erst einmal.
Also quasi die ISS für den Mond.
Genau aber in klein dort wollen wir die Technologien prüfen und testen die wir für eine solche Station um den Mast um später benötigen als sozusagen ein Baustein den welche testen.
Wir wollen eine Raupe auf der App und auf der Mondoberfläche spät auf der Marsoberfläche bedienen ohne Zeitverzögerung später dann auch.
Cups sind landen lassen und wieder hoch fliegen lassen zu dieser Orbitalstation auch erstmal unbemannt und später,
dann benannt also dass wir gratulieren LOGI entwickeln aufbauen Technologie die abgestimmtes die wir dann brauchen für ein langfristiges nachhaltiges Konzept.
Dann wollen wir natürlich auf dem Mond landen und eine kleine Mondstation aufbauen ich stell mir das persönlich so vor wie eine Antarktis Forschungsstation.
Hector die deutsche Neumayer-Station mit ein paar Leuten bis hin zu dieser mcmurdo-station der Amerikaner die im Sommer über 1000 Leute beherbergt also dass das kann auch wachsen ich stell mir das als.
Globale Repräsentation vor das heißt alle Länder der Erde die an.
Der Mond Forschung mitarbeiten wollen sollten dort vertreten sein also ISAF Partner natürlich + China + die neuen Spieler und.
Dann natürlich langfristig geht es zum Horizont viel Maß und über den Martin aus.
Bin ganz charmant eigentlich.
Strukturiert jeder baut jedes Bauteil jeder Schritt macht Sinn Essen wichtiges Puzzlestück für das ganze und das ist die Roadmap die Europa sich.
Gegeben hat um den Weltraum zu erkunden und das zusammen auch mit den internationalen Partnern durchzuführen.
Was für Zeitrahmen sprechen wenn ich etwas was wäre oder was was meint man was vielleicht realistische sein könnte wenn es keine politischen Hindernisse gibt die es gibt.
Ja guter Übergang von einer institutionellen erdnahen Station zu einer kommerziellen Station,
stimmt Amerikaner ja für 20-24 oder Ende 20-24 an Übergang ISAF das hat mir eben beleuchtet,
dann eine Orbitale Mondstation das soll glaube ich 20-22 I Modul gestartet werden.
Die sms diese schwerlastrakete mit der Orion Kapsel soll 20-22 dann zum ersten Mal Richtung Mond wenn man fliegen und.
Hast du schon beschlossen dass es diese Orbitalstation geben soll.
Er sich mal in Planung.
Plant aber es braucht noch ein paar zusagen.
Genau genau genau aber,
die Absichtserklärung von amerikanischer Seite ist eigentlich da und in der ganzen Entwicklungs Kette und begründe warum wird diese amerikanische schwerlastrakete SLS jetzt brauchen hängt ganz stark auch damit zusammen dass wir ihm diese Orbitale Mondstation aufbauen wollen,
Europa hat bisher noch keine Zusage gemacht Finanzierungszusage gemacht aber die haben ja auch erst.
Ende 2019 und dann wechseln Council und dann wird sicher natürlich ein Thema sein macht Europa damit dann.
Klar das Moon village was von dem esa Generaldirektor immer mal wieder ins Spiel gebracht wird ist in Konzept eine eine Vision eine Vision.
Die sehr viel Sinn macht um den Leuten zu erklären was wollen wir eigentlich aber das ist jetzt kein,
Programm was eins zu eins umgesetzt wird in wenigen Jahren ich denke dieses Moon village wird eine langfristige Vision sein aus diesem Mondstation mit ein paar Leute.
Auf dem Boden des Mondes kann sich entwickeln langfristig in eine größere Station was dann vielleicht mal irgendwann Moon village genannt wird.
Das Band ein Leitmotiv.
Genau genau sehr schön.
Und der Flug Richtung Mars die die Suche nach Leben oder nach Spuren von Leben ist natürlich in NP Madras wir langfristig angehen werden ich denke das wird wahrscheinlich nach 20201 bemannt durchgeführt werden.
Die Chinesen haben jetzt schon geplant 20-30 zum ersten Mal bemannt auf dem Mond zu landen also das ist sozusagen eine Enddatum.
Was ich glaube was wir umsetzen werden es wird spannend sein zu sehen ob die Amerikaner vorher bereits wieder auf dem Mond landen werden.
Sollen wir jetzt alle anrufen und sagt hier Matthias willst nicht mal zum Mars fliegen wäre das was.
Raten würde ich dir etwas sagen wie sieht's denn mit dem Rückreiseticket aus wenn das ziemlich sicher wäre wird jetzt sagen lass uns mal über Details reden.
Böser schon nicht und Haft so also set,
Übermaß 500 auch schon mal berichtet also 7 psychologische Experimente die analysiert haben wie sich so Leute überhaupt auf seiner Reise besonders lange Zeit Unterhalt für die ganzen technischen Herausforderung mal ganz abgesehen.
Ja also ich,
denke mit der jetzigen Technologie können wir noch nicht Richtung Mars fliegen wenn ich mir die Orion Kapsel anschaue Modell steht ja schon in den USA der Trainingshalle dort war dann auch schon mit meinen europäischen Kollegen drin in dieser,
Kapsel Mann sitzt zu viert sehr beengt da drin,
wenn ich mir vorstelle dort allein 23 Wochen Richtung Mond zu fliegen und dann länger Mond ob ich zu bleiben Mann ist zu viert nimm ganz engen Raum wann muss gleichzeitig,
machen dann muss aber auch wenn man sich waschen oder auf Toilette gehen für zwei Wochen geht das vielleicht aber 500 helfe ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen wollen auf so engem Raum,
da das dann zu machen dann müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen Zusatzmodule mit einpacken bevor werde ich doch mal fliegen und diese gibt's momentan noch nicht.
Also viele Herausforderung ich sage erstmal vielen Dank.
Dann eigenemissionen gibt's noch nicht aber ich hoffe das wird sich dann auch irgendwann.
Ist auch noch die Zahnziehen aber der Horizont liegt näher.
Also mit Samantha ist erst mal gesprochen hatte bei dieselbe Situation das hat sich ja dann alles eingefunden ja noch mal vielen Dank für die.
Von hier zur Zukunft der Raumfahrt so in den nächsten Jahrzehnten das war's jetzt hier erstmal bei Raumzeit bedank mich wie immer fürs zuhören und sag tschüss und bis bald.